sup Andrew what's up Stephen I made you
a letter
we'll get brunch will you go to brunch
with me about this yeah I'll go to
brunch with you okay I spent 20 days on
that get even waste of time
not worth it tell me about brunch I'll
tell you about brunch brunch is dumb
brunch is not dumb brunch is an event
it's a place where you can extend
breakfast into lunch and create a new
memory a memory that we shall call
brunch today on worth it we're gonna be
trying three brunches at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price and actually we're doing
the brunch across three Sundays triple
the fun triple the action for long in
the pain he says that but he truly loves
me so the first place we're going to is
in fact not a brunch place yes they
serve breakfast but they serve it from 8
a.m. to 3 p.m. so what do you do when
you breakfast at 3 p.m.
isn't that a combination of breakfast
and dinner what well you are you going
here Brenner Roper
[Laughter]
I'm Brianna I'm call me breezy I'm the
owner and founder of home state and
today we're gonna be eating breakfast
tacos when you started home state did
you initially see it as a breakfast taco
primarily yes in case oh my mission of
mine was deserved breakfast tacos and
queso because no one else in LA was
doing that I was like this is crazy we
opened with really bad cases I thought
we were gonna go down because like you
know it's a big deal we finally got it
about a year after we opened was a
secret it's real cheese blended with
jalapeno Serrano's onions tomatoes it's
a huge part of your dr. Charcot
experience because we need to dip the
taco in that case own and we'll take
your dining experience from here too
like you have to do the Trinity by a
country mile like our most favorite I
love taco it's on a flour tortilla large
tortilla is king in Texas we make the
tortillas by hand they're made fresh to
order
we have scrambled eggs which are really
beautifully cooked too topped with
crispy potatoes crispy bacon and melted
cheddar cheese I like that we're having
coffee is the first beverage that we
have in this episode because brunch is
nothing but breakfast see this is why
you're on this trip I'm here to educate
you Cheers
start with the Trinity let's go the
tortilla smells incredible it's like a
baby's thigh so soft and squishy in a
good way okay ahead away okay Cheers
Wow
that's so good yeah oh it is at
face-value pretty basic breakfast
components but with the tortilla it's so
much more the egg is the game-changer
here it fills your mouth with the thing
that egg does which tastes good and it's
fluffy oh man this is amazing
this combination luscious we're also
gonna do that vegetarian taco when I was
living in Texas I was vegetarian for 12
years for me Legend and Terry and taco
was pretty critical it sounds like a
boring taco until you try it
but it's the Blanco it's egg white with
shiitake mushrooms and Monterey cheese I
love this taco as much as I love you I
wish I could say the same is it because
you love me so much that it doesn't
compare that's what I'm hearing mushroom
is as powerful a flavor as any meat
budget Aryan friends sometimes you like
a disorder than the stick you can't eat
brisket can't eat bacon but it's okay
because they have designed this
beautiful simple taco just for you the
final tacos at Pecos which is another
favorite and that's also really simple
it's just scrambled eggs and shredded
brisket and the brisket is cooked for 12
hours we do nothing to it but to put
salt and pepper on
which is a really great quality be nice
and slow yeah what more did in life then
egg brisket and flour tortillas cheese
on top maybe you know I do have to see
in a little bit corrected this is way
more than breakfast I'm eating slow
roasted brisket can we talk about the
brisket you talk about the tortillas
some more can we talk about the egg it's
perfect with just a little bit of salsa
oh thank you that's what best friends do
there you go my friend has anybody ever
told you that you taking really large
bites oh God did you think we did that
wrong we should have got two tacos each
but that's why you eat brunch at you
know 11:00 a.m. then you get the rest of
Sunday just nap brunch in that brown
spec brunch is speculated to have come
from men who used to hunt in the UK they
would need to get their nourishment so
they would eat breakfast and lunch
combined into one large meal with an
adult beverage adult beverage and
hunting sounds like my kind of day
all right governors go hunting oh I
haven't eaten yet shall we combine
breakfast and lunch
that's nonsense let's call it brunch
sounds way better can I enjoy an adult
beverage ordering I wouldn't have it any
other way so we're done for today
it's time for our little nap next week
we're going to a frame and what do they
do there stacks on stacks on stacks on
stacks on stuff all right my name is Roy
welcome to a frame we serve pancakes on
the weekend all you can eat if you look
around so the old high hatha makes sense
to serve pancakes in here we gutted this
whole thing out we saw these beautiful
beams and everything right at the time
we were creating a frame I was going to
Hawaii a lot so I was like channeling
the spirit of the island we were serving
Korean Hawaii inspired who for the first
two years this was that restaurant and
then we decided to open for brunch
personally and professionally you avoid
what's right in front of you finally
confronted you know what a theme works
right well I hope you made it and
all-you-can-eat brunch like to use a
really strong stable daughter milk
recipe just straight-up classic your
grandma wouldn't be mad type of Pancakes
and then from there we add toppings
together
caper order for stacking all you got to
do is raise your hand and just keep
getting filled up why also bottomless
drinks now we try to think of like how
can I make places that everyone can
access yeah so that's what the
all-you-can-drink is we have a michelada
it's like a spicy beer like a Bloody
Mary and a beer head sex
adore techies lager on mimosa and a
Bloody Mary Cheers oh yeah I'm gonna eat
more than you today ha ha ha you would
have breakfast you made a mistake that's
called priming your stomach all right
English tank number one right off the
griddle hot we live event with the
little coy butter this is a passion
fruit butter that we make into compound
butter let's head for this one yum it's
sweet okay you going double double dog
yeah when you need a stack of pancakes
you eat the whole stack at once ah
really yes you separate pink no how do
your style Cheers this is gonna be a
great day excuse me ma eat more Oh nuts
on pancakes picture that together is a
great company yeah yeah it's fluffy and
nutty yeah I'm ready
fluffer nutter you're naughty actually
gonna use a little syrup for me I'm
though I'm a purist pancake number one
down let's go over the next one we have
the banana macadamia nut butter we make
a macadamia nut pesto with banana and
then we serve that with lip cream banana
macadamia nut macadamia macadamia
macadamia all right this is fun having
fun and brunch let's eat
so banana Oh banana and pancake is a
classic combo for me a soft fluffy
texture with a soft mushy texture that
goes so well together your would be buy
it here Cheers
the thing that you just said to value
now but she hands the hop together yeah
that wasn't snapping in my mouth just
now and then we have the pineapple
orange guava which is almost like a jam
can I feed you a bank
[Music]
don't know what you think about that
it's not quite like the others it's a
little more heart and it's got that
pineapple as acidity to it
come on Hawaii like lying in the sand
the world is passing by me and suddenly
some fruit falls from a tree and lands
in your mouth right yeah and then we
have the buttermilk chicken which is our
buttermilk pancake with a mochiko rice
flour fried chicken penne Japanese style
Japanese Hawaiian stuff oh now I kind of
feel like we've finally arrived at
brunch
just one guy Andrew so I bring you on
these thank you so charming and smart
and what a great and I'm gonna eat it
this is the way to do it yeah with the
sweeter ones and then when lunch comes
around 11:00 a.m. 12:00 p.m. you go to
your rest of the lunch hours this is the
first time we had the buttermilk pancake
on its own it's beautiful you get with
fried chicken I didn't have it together
you made the mistake do it yeah I'll
give you some of mine
you have the fried chicken coughing
[ __ ] pancake a dynamic duo of
friendship I think we have a special
treat for Adam
[Music]
Matt thanks for driving appreciate it
allow me to enjoy a drink on the show
what you think what do you think dude
that was so good unlimited pancakes
yeah come on come on pancakes are
delicious runs fat dude I have to piece
the head that's not a brunch those
mimosas in water glasses I tickle you
will you P brunch back brunch was
popularized in America most likely
because as actors were traveling from
the east coast to the west coast they
would stop by Chicago for a mid-morning
meal planes couldn't fly it you know all
the way across the coast they would stop
in the middle of the country and then
finish the flight at the end Wow it
melted my brain melted your brain melted
it like butter on a pancake so we've had
breakfast tacos we've had our guinea
pancakes and finally we're on the way to
the last spot next week I'll see you
next week the ultimate brunch seafood
champagne no caviar
my name is Dave Academy I'm the
executive chef of the peninsula Beverly
Hills and you are here to dine with us
for Sunday brunch we like to do things
that are just fun a little bit different
more of the old-school nod to how brunch
is used to be it's done with a modern
twist you know we like things where it's
slower paced people can walk through at
their leisure
hence the champagne so you can just sit
there and have fun and if you don't like
your family you can always drink a
little bit more and I think brunch is
like the ultimate way to like win
somebody's heart right I would agree
first dates family time and when it gets
awkward you just eat more we feature for
our Sunday brunch many many many
different items we have jumbo shrimp
cocktail Easter snow crab claws Reuben
bass scallop seviche house smoked salmon
we do a taramosalata which is a Greek
cod road dip we also have braised pork
belly lamb pastrami it's usually done
with a brisket but we use a leg of lamb
so we cure it and brine it for three
days and then we smoke it for four hours
and then slowly roast it overnight lamb
for Army that's not a typical thing
right no it's a little twist
everything's a twist the lobster waffle
is probably one of our signature dishes
it's basically a play on chicken and
waffles if you will matter is Yukon Gold
potatoes a little bit of flour some
magic some love and buttermilk on and on
top we do a very acidic Bernays I think
a lot of burn aces are very muted and
they just become very fatty but you have
this rich potato waffle you have lobster
it's very light and then we just want to
air it out with everything else there's
an art to eating a buffet you always
want more than what you can finish if
you leave fat and happy I'm happy that's
the whole point so there will be plenty
of food for Adams they'll be plenty of
food for Adam I think we're ready to do
it great yeah
crush it crush crush crush brunch isn't
a phrase that I expect coming out of a
place like glowing crush it yeah thanks
for dressing up for once
whoo that's been smooth we need to crush
this brunch so I think we need a game
plan here I think you should cheers the
the lamb no the waffle lobster la la oh
you want to lead with the waffle lobster
yeah it's one of the few things that we
can pick up
hmm oh yeah mmm there's like chunks of
potato in the waffle who's this
delightful cream on top
chicken and waffles you think you've
reached the pinnacle of life when you
try that mm-hmm
lobster and waffles yeah yeah okay that
inducing shrimp is I don't think I've
ever had a shrimp that fat and juicy in
my life mmm muscle - stop dogging holy
Sh
beating the shrimp yeah mount it up cop
a shrimp in their mouth
mmm on the same theme here boom on come
on his next level oh yeah easy there big
fella just trying to cross is brunch
let's see the lamb
[Music]
Cheers no joke
Wow yeah that's crazy that lamb is so
tender to bite into you're the best part
of brunches get delicious seafood the
best of breakfast you had a beautifully
carved lamb then if you want to you just
have a doughnut right after that there's
a really good doughnut everything head
nice um ah man
where did you expect those weren't
biting into cream cheese belly no I
didn't actually didn't get pork belly
wow that was so soft it's like mashed
potatoes like pig jello you know I dream
about that big jello yes thank you Oh
Tom oh yeah why not grouches when you
want to become a Greek god beating
yourself like grapes like this mmm
shoving Donuts I think more than
anything else brunch is about taking
your time to eat just whatever you want
gonna get it now you feel it be for the
love the good times the memories that
you'll never forget
oh yeah I love brunch were you wearing a
bell earlier I had to take it off
because of the constriction all right
Andrew which brunch was the most worth
as price to you my favorite brunch spas
home state because if you want a
low-impact brunch you can have it there
and if you want to ball hard and dip
your breakfast taco into a cheese pool
you could do that too actually no a
frame is my word that way sorry
uh-uh no home state is my worth it
winner yeah you can't go one way and
then go the other way and then go the
other way the problem is that wreck fish
tacos are such a good savory breakfast
food and pancakes are such a good sweet
it's really hard to choose between them
I gotta say my worth it winner I mean
you know what my fake a frame that
macadamia pancake oh my gosh I'm still
dreaming about it Adam Adam I win
you don't win this is the first time on
the show he picked something with me
shoutout to Belvedere though whose great
seafood lovers out there got your spot
next time you see this we might be in
Japan
[Music]
Hey
sorry to the editor Oh oh yes
[Music]